okay we are officially live everything
should be on the up and up I hope you
guys are an excited as I am I love doing
these these Q&A sessions I would have
been live earlier but I had a very very
late night last night and so um at the
moment before I actually started this
I'm working on a couple videos for Rob
explains I'm working on a video about
how genes and chromosomes and DNA are
related to one another how they work to
form complex life and I'm also working
on a video about how what in the heck
there's a video like buffering really
bad for you guys okay no it's not okay
cool it was giving me fits for a minute
I don't understand why but I'm also
working on a video for Rob explains
about what happens when you turn our
life switch how contactors and all that
kind of stuff working and so on and then
this week we'll have age of apocalypse
finished I'm working on a video about
old man Logan the importance of old man
Logan why that story was a huge deal for
Wolverine fans of Marvel comic fans and
that video will be very similar to the
Gwen Stacy video and the Civil War video
and then I'm working on a video about
maestro the the Hulk of all hoaxes like
that big guy very very important
character he's a really cool character
for for the incredible hulk I'd love the
maestro from the future imperfect event
he was he was so cool he was brutal he
was harsh but it was it was really cool
so um anyway so what's going on
everybody how's your how's your
afternoon coming along how's your day
how's your day coming along I mean how
you guys are feeling how are y'all
feeling today I'm listening to a hip-hop
compilation right now it's like this
chill like it's a compilation of like
hip hop beats you know that's that's
actually pretty solid like I really dig
it oh if I could write one title for any
comic what would it be uh hmm hello um
God if I can make a title read one one
half of the time okay and just to make
sure I understand our when you say to
write one half of a title are you saying
like or write one title for any Kali
book like would if I could write the
book itself or just make the title I
mean I don't like what do you mean just
would be a little more clear um yeah
i'll explain vaping at some point in
time um thoughts on all new all
different Miles Morales actually don't I
haven't heard anything about the new all
different the all different all new
mouse mouse so they changing its
character up I mean is it going to be
like a different Miles Morales I don't
know I haven't heard anything yet um
let's see I love the way you're bringing
back the old type of videos yeah it got
a little it got a little burning you
know like a little a little it get a
little mundane it was just like okay
here's what happens here in this and
then that and whatever and I was
actually a little nervous when I threw
the music into that civil war video and
the Gwen Stacy videos like man I'm a lot
of people are going to receive this but
I was like whatever let's just give it a
shot and just see what happens and and
people really really love it i mean
there's a few naysayers there's always
going to be naysayers i mean i don't i
don't worry about them so much but like
you guys really really seem to dig you
know the the the because what i'm doing
is kind of a combination like with the
old man logan video for example the old
man logan video what I'm doing is I'm
saying like here's the old man Logan
story summarized and you know i don't
know maybe maybe three or four minutes
and then here's the importance of old
man logan here's why I mattered and here
is why Wolverine fans and Marvel comic
fans like needed old man Logan because
we really really needed that story like
we we needed old man Logan to happen
like people were at their wit's end when
it came to Wolverine and Marvel Comics
like people were really really losing it
um Miles Morales is a new spider-man
going forward post secret wars okay that
makes sense that makes perfect sense to
me in truth guys it was only a matter of
time before that happened but um anyway
so yeah um you know that's that's the
basis behind old man Logan that's what
that's what I'll be doing with that you
know with with that video but that's
going to be like I think the nature of
those explaining videos going forward is
a combination of years you know because
in the old man Logan video is like okay
explain the old man Logan story then
here's how Wolverine first came about
here's why he was created here's how
fans received his characters and hear
how here's how his character changed
over the course of the you know whatever
was 20 some-odd 30 years or so before
they gave us old man Logan so um anyway
let's see so Rob what if in the MCU
Doctor Strange taught scarlet witch
magic and it ends up going out of
control and we get an MC version of
house of em but without the whole mutant
thing see that's a really cool thing
about the house of him you don't need
mutants like you don't need the x-men to
do House of M house of him was it was
easier like the way that okay for those
of you guys have never read house of m
scott at which of course lost her mind
use her powers to work reality but what
she did is she had taken Charles Xavier
and she had read his mind and she had
used his knowledge or used his mind to
read the mind of everybody else and to
figure out what it was they wanted the
most and so when she launched the House
of M she gave everybody exactly what
they dreamed of and so of course it
ended up being you know skewed
respectively there's nothing to say that
that you know dr. strange giving her
powers or teaching her how to use magic
allows her to read minds I mean we know
she can do that now by tapping into
people's greatest fears we don't know if
it's really her ability to read their
minds and know if she could read their
fears or if she just casts a hex that
just brings their fears to their minds
we don't really know how that works what
we do know is that she can influence the
mind and so there's nothing to say that
somewhere along the line a House of M
does happen in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe I don't think it will I don't
think we'll get um get a house of m
event it'd be cool if we did I'd love to
see it I love to see like like twisted
dystopian futures you know alternate
timelines are just really dark because
everybody loves like those really dark
futures you know like what if everyone
was dead you know that kind of thing but
um you know I'd love to see that I just
I don't me know if we saw something
along the lines of House of M you're
talking about much later on down line on
the model Cinematic Universe phase 4 5 6
7 something like that but not really
sure hey Rob recently read my first what
if comic which one is your favorite um
ah there was actually one that I thought
was really interesting
was age of Ultron what if and what had
happened was when Wolverine of course at
the end of age of Ultron had screwed up
time one of the stories was that Hank
Pam was the last surviving human win
Ultron had taken over the world he had
killed everybody else and at the end of
the comic you actually find out that
Hank Pym is an Ultron robot himself and
just didn't find out until the end of
the story and it was really cool like it
was really really a cool concept what's
going on you wastes I think that's how
you pronounce it you ways but um it was
a really cool concept you know when it
when it launched and I was really really
digging it I was like that's awesome you
know but all the other age of Ultron
stories what if stories were stupid but
that was my favorite one of my favorite
ones so um do you think we'll get a
proper Dark Phoenix and the x-men film
universe and truth it depends on
apocalypse the problem is is that i
don't i think bryan singer said that
apocalypse is going to be the last x-men
film that he makes and so it's going to
be kind of left to whoever else can make
them and Fox would probably keep making
x-men films if it's not bryan singer and
truth I don't really know who it is
that's going to give us any kind of a
imma be imma was going to give us any
kind of a dark phoenix kind of story and
who's gonna be able to give us that that
sort of thing um it'd be cool if we did
see it it'd be cool if we saw Jean Grey
just progressively lose her mind when
she becomes or i guess the Phoenix lose
her mind when it becomes caught up in
the emotions you know that composed Jean
Grey's you know psyche Jean Grey's mine
was she had copied her but I don't know
i don't think i don't think we'll see i
think that at this point given x-men 3
the Fox is going to kind of stay away
from a whole Phoenix force thinks is
they they really really screw that up
Rob you're awesome any chance of you
coming to New York City yes we will
actually be at New York City for a new
york comic con and for those of you guys
who are in the dallas area who happen to
catch this this life she can keep in
mind myself and benny and aunt Drake
will be at be at Arlington i think or
dallas dallas / arlington will be there
for a fan meet up of course we have it
posted on twitter we have a facebook
then i'll make sure i post a link in the
in the description of this video but um
you make sure you guys come out and
check us out because we would we'd love
to
with you guys and like I want to get
autograph some people who show up so I
don't how many people are going to show
but either way you know it'd be kind of
cool to to make it out there um and now
I don't play League of Legends favorite
MCU villain Loki hands down definitely
Loki he's such a cool guy like I love
the low key character um let's see rah
hey well I just wanted to say you're one
of the people that got me started on
vaping just quit cigarettes good for you
well I'm initial thought tastes it
tastes way better yeah I'm glad that you
got away from say I love being away from
cigarettes like cigarette smell terrible
now like it's it's awful but um it's one
of the reasons why I don't hang around a
lot of my friends that much is because
they all like a lot of them still smoke
and I don't like unlike the smell so
good so now I don't I'm gonna be with
that um greetings hi Rob readings from
the Netherlands the Netherlands oops
hold on a second there we go I love your
vids quick question do you think well I
think I may have let's see scroll back
up because there's so many questions
coming in from you guys it's absolutely
nuts hey guys just like bombard
questions scroll down scroll down scroll
down to go down let's go down there we
go question do you think old man Logan
is going to kick apocalypses ass uh I'm
not really sure but that was an amazing
ending to that story God like Venice is
doing a great job writing old man Logan
I'm really psyched with it like I'm
really really enjoying it um man I don't
know um it'd be cool if he did I don't
know if he will but it'd be cool if
they're like of the two of them fought
I'm really hoping that happens um hey
Rob in honor of ripping off Jurassic
world do you think we might see em see
you Savage Land movie I don't know if I
mean Savage Land didn't rip off jurassic
world Savage Land was around decades
before Jurassic
before Jurassic Park the savage lands
been around since Claremont I think
since like the 1980s um I don't think
we'll see a Savage Land movie because
people would think it'd be a ripoff of a
Jurassic world so um what comic series
do I think will be after Secret Wars
honestly like I have no idea i mean
information is slowly tricking trickling
out of Marvel about what the world is
going to look like after Secret Wars is
over um we don't know I mean I'm sure
we'll see some series with Wolverine we
may or may not see something with
Deadpool no idea at this point armor
wars is weird not really big an armor
worse too much don't know if we really
see anything from Tony Stark I think the
models using a lot of these stories to
determine what we're going to see after
secret ward i think they're looking at
like you know planet hulk and they're
looking at deadpool suger secret wars
and they're looking at old man logan and
a lot of those stories you know i guess
x 192 when that comes out they'll be
looking at years of future past and
they'll be determining whether or not
they're going to you know continue a lot
of these characters you know after
singer wars or if they're going to get
their own solo stories but again we just
don't know i definitely want to see old
man logan you know continued on beyond
that but you know i think that that you
know again that's not from that it's
really too difficult to tell at this
point which Marvel character would make
the best Batman um probably Marc Spector
and probably moon night he make a really
solid Batman there's a couple of the
characters too I think daredevil would
make a really good Batman let's see who
also make a really good Batman um
Captain America would make a more heroic
like a less dark version about man but
he still be very capable in the role of
Batman um I don't only a couple of
characters that I haven't that I can't
really think of but I'm liking Inferno
an old man Logan inferno is decent
enough um you know after reading the
original Inferno event I'm not really
sure I mean the original Inferno event
really just gave us the whole backstory
behind Madeleine prior like that was the
main focus of it won't not really the
main focus that's what I was looking
forward when you know when I read
through inferno that was my big my big
thing I mean some of other things that
we saw you know of course the whole
Ileana Rasputin and the queen of the
demon world and the original Inferno
though she actually turned away from
becoming the demon queen and this
Inferno event it looks like she's
embraced it so you know it's it's it's I
think Inferno is okay there's definitely
not anything that I'm derp definitely
not anything that I'm rushing to the
comic book store to buy but it's decent
enough you know Matt Murdock would be a
badass Batman yes he would hookers the
Batman no way that would be ridiculous
um why do I love this century sounds
cool but I haven't gotten into him yet
it's really more of the story about the
century than this entry himself this
entry himself is a wildly interesting
like like Robert Reynolds is not that
great of a character especially when
he's part of the New Avengers the story
about this century is what makes him
really cool like I'd never read a story
like that in Marvel before and so it was
really really intriguing um favorite
artists definitely jlee I love jellies
art probably probably some of my
favorite art in in Marvel Comics just
the way it looks and the darkness of it
the grittiness of it and looks when he
draw stuff it looks almost as though
you're looking at it through a dream
like through a cloudy mist dream you
know kind of thing it looks really
really cool let's see what do you think
will be the next overall arc for the
model Cinematic Universe I don't know
you know I thought civil war was going
to be the next like overarching thing
but I don't think we really going to get
that I think we're just going to get
like a single movie based on the war
it's whatever it'll be fun um after
infinity war I have no clue I mean I
have I have no earthly clue you know how
all that works out um you know it'll be
interesting you know to see how it
progresses but I mean there's so many
things that they could do but there's
also so many things they can't do not
having the Fantastic Four and not having
the x-men really limits what it is that
they're capable of achieving I may for
example they can't do like maximum
security you know I don't know why they
wouldn't know whether would want to but
they can't do maximum security you know
they can't do you know the whole Phoenix
saga you know they can't do the Future
Foundation there's a lot of things I
can't do
which I imagine Holly why Marvel is kind
of fighting you know to try to get the
rights back at some point that's
important time but at this point man
it's you know it's weird 300,000 Subs
coming up doing anything special yes I'm
god I'm working on so many videos I need
to work on on something awesome for you
guys to say thank you you know I mean I
mean I may give something away yeah I'm
a giveaway giveaway a book or something
like that you know um let's see mm-hmm
Rob where is your damn coffee that
better be a coffee flavored juice in
your vape no it is not this is actually
called gamma by cloud science it is a
guava strawberry cream flavored juice
and I have some drink from so I'm drink
from jimmy johns I do not have coffee
because it is 615 in the evening and
it's way too late to be drinking coffee
so let's see could the MCU do Secret
Invasion I wouldn't want to see it to be
honest I really would I really would not
want to see well you could do see if
they could do Secret Invasion and use
its like retcon everything but I mean it
would seem cheap and it'd be kind of
kind of silly so um give away a statue
a favorite superhero video game ooh
that's a good one um listen to this
really cool hip hop song this is a
really cool song when you guys get a
chance look up what is this called what
is a song called this is a good song
it's kind of like a really cool like a
groovy beat to it I really dig it look
up a sweet talk by vanilla like it's got
this really cool you know jazzy vibe too
and I really dig this this is awesome um
I forgot what you asked I forgot your
question Oh favorite video game um
definitely maximum carnage and like
maximum carnage was solid back in the
day it was it was probably the first you
know comic book superhero video game
that I played and I never got past the
first level I'm it took me forever to
realize you could walk up the wall like
I never figured that out and yeah I was
I was dumb as a kid let's see thoughts
on marvel vs DC video game um as far as
I know they don't have one unless you're
talking about like the old Capcom games
but um you know I really wouldn't mind
seeing I wouldn't mind seeing like a
return to that you know kind of a Capcom
you know bring I guess the return of the
model vs DC universe I'd rather see one
that was more along the lines of like
you know marvel ultimate alliance that
play that same way you know more like a
strategy game that would be more fun but
I wouldn't I be down for it I think it'd
be kind of cool um no I haven't read
Justice League number 41 yet I need to
but i've been i've been working on video
i am the worst when it comes to time
management like I I second time
management so like I need to like yeah I
think that I need to get better at it
it's pitiful it's apocalypse an old man
Logan the same we saw in doctor dooms
castle we think so that seems to be the
case I don't know why I wouldn't be um
but we haven't seen multiple verses of
apocalypse yet so I don't know I would
think so I would think that's probably
the case but I'm not sure
um let's see who would make the best
green lantern in the model Cinematic
Universe who who would make a good green
lantern and the model cinematic mirror
hmm who would make a good green lantern
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe like
just moral Cinematic Universe characters
i think phil coulson would make a good
Green Lantern like I could take him are
you talking about of the Green Lantern's
that have existed which one should exist
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe because
I'll be kind of interesting let's see
hey Rob out of the whole marvel universe
who do you hate the most but respect a
lot ah who do I hate the most but
respect a lot I mean I don't really
there really isn't anybody that I hate
and respect if I don't like their
character I don't really respect their
character so um let's see what so I mean
okay I got me I don't have an answer to
that question there's nobody who's
character I hate but respect like I
don't I mean I don't mean not really um
what superhero should get their own
netflix show uh mm-hmm well we know that
they're kind of tender there they are
yeah I hate spider-man like I don't like
spider-man and all we know they're
testing the waters with the punisher you
know but Jon Bernthal being being hired
to play the roller being you know put
into the role of of the Punisher um I
don't know I mean there's there's some
really dark gritty carriage i think the
punisher should get his own netflix TV
show I think it'd be really cool I think
that he will I think that we'll see you
a Punisher Netflix TV show because I
think that he'll be written really
really well in the in the Netflix series
so far for daredevil but but yeah I'd
say the punisher should probably get his
own um have i read the secret war tie-in
of Runaways no I don't like the runaways
I never had like the runaways I never
got into them they just never really did
anything for me um you respect him but
you really hate doom I'd love doom like
dude is amazing like I love doctor do
because he's so arrogant you know he's
he's like the most arrogant person ever
but he can also back it up to and that's
that's the funny thing so um let's see
if you could only watch one TV show this
year which one would it be oh definitely
God moon nights a really good choice too
I didn't think about midnight um i would
say i mean we're talking about counting
book based TV shows because if i only
had to watch 1 i'd probably watch the
flash so um who would win in a fight
juggernaut versus the flash the
juggernaut he would just he wouldn't
tire out I mean when Cain Marko has the
power of the juggernaut he doesn't need
sleep he doesn't need food he doesn't
need water he doesn't need anything he
could just survive on the power of the
juggernaut um he would definitely
outlast the flash easily um hey brah why
does Sal hey Talan more I don't think
Sal hates a lot more but it's funny to
hear his impression of him so hey Rob
love your channel I was wondering why do
Marvel fans dislike name with a
submariner and Hank pan both of my
favorite characters and I just wanted to
know your opinion on those characters
well you can't do like a broad
generalization like that you can't say
like Marvel fans hate men with a
submariner and Hank Pym there's some
fans that love him to some fans that
don't um you know people like me I mean
I don't really care that much about man
with a submariner he had his time he was
the first mutant he was really big back
in the day but he's just kind of benin
cared to this existed in the background
he just doesn't really matter that much
anymore you know i would say that his
involvement in in time runs out it's
probably the most significant
involvement that he's had in the last
you know hello since civil war maybe and
the only reason why he had a big role in
civil war is because everybody had a
role in civil war
um you know with Hank Pym Hank Pym
really it really kind of depends I mean
you have a lot of a lot of fans out
there that hey Hank Pam you know because
you know they like to make fun of the
faculty he'd smack and we hit his wife
some don't like him because of the fact
that he made Ultron some think that you
know it's that there's really not much
to his character and in truth there
really isn't a whole lot to Hank Pym you
know there really isn't a whole lot to
him as an individual he made he made an
Ultron he rebuilt Ultron at one point
when he was being brainwashed he hit his
wife and that's really it like that's
that is the story of Hank Pym and Marvel
Comics you know it's not he's not
relevant anymore you know it's not you
know I don't know it's just one of those
weird things I guess um hey Rob do you
think Thanos will acquire the power gym
the one the Guardians have if you think
he will get the power gym at all 12
course he is he's going to be assembling
the Infinity Gauntlet he's going to get
like he's going to get the power gym so
um well Deadpool be part over the
diplomat be part of the MCU and if so
how will it work with the whole breaking
the fourth wall thing and crossover no
dead phones like me part of the MCU guys
dead fools a fox film not a Marvel film
unless something comes up and Marvel
gets the rights to Deadpool or some kind
of an agreements worked out with Fox in
the same way that they worked out an
agreement with sony and spider-man I
don't think that's going to happen um
and let's see hey Rob who do you think
was the best Harold um probably Silver
Surfer my favorite one he's like The
Herald of Galactus when people think of
heralds of Galactus they think of the
Silver Surfer first and then like
everybody else second Rob do you think
that graviton will be a great enough
villain to green enough of a threat of a
villain in the MCU after Thanos is taken
care of graviton would be a great
earthbound villain he would be a great
villain for like just the Avengers to
deal with I mean a guy that could
manipulate the force of gravity I mean
right off the bat he can you know he can
really can definitely inflict some
damage on all the characters I mean just
like you saw on Avengers you know in the
vengers cartoon show you could
definitely hold his own against the
Incredible Hulk there's a lot that he
could do um he'd be a solid villain to
have I mean I'm not go see a villain
that had graviton a lot of people
the problem here is la pipa wouldn't
know who he is if they advertise the
movie and they said you know coming in
phase for Avengers you know for is going
to be eating Avengers vs graviton people
are going to be like well who the hell's
graviton like I know who that guy is and
in fans are you know I guess casual
moviegoers are going to be like one and
they're going to be the good thing is
kind of weird no um graviton was not an
agent of shield not that I know of hey
Rob have you read the comic wayward and
if so what are your thoughts I have not
read wayward i'm gonna read very many
indie comics i don't really read
anything the only one that i read is the
walking dead a deadpool SS true deadpool
was a good Harold I mean Thor was a
herald on may was a herald there were a
lot of people who were Herald of
Galactus let's see hey Rob do you think
Marvel will ever get back the rights to
get the right back to x-men will they
explain the origin of Quicksilver and
Scarlet Witch um I don't think I don't
think they'll get the rights back to the
x-men the x-men is just too it just
makes too much money I mean I don't
think that's going to happen you know
MODOK in the MCU now I wouldn't i
wouldn't go see a movie with MODOK to
the incident marvel cinematic universe
would be silly i'm in a giant floating
head in a chair I mean it would be now
it be goosey um let's see graviton was
Opie wasn't he yeah he was really
overpowered I got the community Locker
manipulate graviton particles the
particles the control gravity I mean no
he was it was stupid how powerful that
guy was um let's see would you like to
see Kane to conquer in a movie that'd be
cool it'd be a cool way to involve time
travel the problem came the Conqueror is
you know he really wasn't a villain that
appealed to me that much it really
wasn't as though I were a you know read
a comic that I came to conquer and I was
like oh my god it's Kang the Conqueror
like yes this is going to be such a
great story you know I didn't really
care about it that much do you I think
world war hulk should be adapted for the
MCU yes I think they should really adapt
world war hulk for the Marvel cinnamon
universe the problem that i have with
with that is what would the build-up be
like okay how would I mean how would you
build it up I mean right now at the
innovative Ultron hook was just like I
guys like I gotta bail I gotta go do
some stuff and you know whatever and
he's just vanished I off of some island
somewhere you know we don't know where
he is now we don't know what he's doing
right now um what were hope I mean it
would have to be a reason for him to
come back and and freaked out you know
it has to be a reason for him to come
back and lose his mind on everybody
right now I don't know how would they
would do that I have no idea what that
story would be or how that would happen
no I don't gallatin was in episode 3 of
agents of shield okay that's cool um you
know I don't know um I don't know how
that would happen you know how that
would how that would all come to
fruition I would dig it I'd loved it you
know I'd love to see how it happened you
know but um it'd be interesting you know
to see how it all however it all play
out which hope movie do I prefer the one
with Edward Norton definitely a whole
lot better do you collect anything else
other than comics yeah I've actually I
got a whole bunch of new books yeah I
actually had a whole bunch of new books
this is a book that I'm reading right
now the the Third Reich at war basically
talking about how the Third Reich rose
to power and what happened when the
Third Reich was in power what led to the
rise of adolf hitler and nazi germany I
mean all those all those things you know
really important aspects of history in
the world and so on that is that's
that's a really a really cool book on
one of the one of the interesting things
actually is that well we don't get into
a discussion I I'm gonna do a discussion
about Adolf Hitler during the live
stream but nonetheless you know Adolf
Hitler's rise to power was actually
really intriguing if you get into the
intricacies of it it's it's kind of wild
why is that was powerful without the
gauntlet I get he's big and ripped but
didn't Squirrel Girl to feed him what
makes him so threatening especially in
the MCU everyone seems to
cower at is mentioned okay that was
being defeated my squirrel girl was more
of like a joke you know it was it was
just kind of like the it was it was a
little bit of a comedic thing um it is
canon as far as we know like it actually
did happen so I don't know I mean it
took place Thanos is announced as a
character that for all intents and
purposes one can't die because he's been
banished from the realm of mistress
death with means he can he's immortal he
could never be killed and two because
he's so intelligent like he's
intelligent and he's extremely strong
and that is a very dangerous combination
for him to have so that's pretty much
the reason why so many people get
freaked out about his character because
he's one of the most dangerous
characters in the entire Marvel Universe
who do I think would make the best
Shazam and what's all these weird
questions about having like DC
characters in the Marvel and the Marvel
Cinematic Universe that's that's weird
because he's purple do I like that I
like Thomas Jane is a Punisher
definitely time machine is the punisher
was pretty stellar like I really dug
that version um I would love to have
seen Thomas Jane come back and play The
Punisher in the Netflix series I don't
know whether he actually turned down the
role or not I don't know if he was even
approached you know I mean jon bernthal
is great choice he's a great actor he's
really really intense when he gets to
know when he gets into that in that
intense character I think he'd do great
as Frank Castle but i really would have
liked to have seen Thomas Jane come back
so Brian Michael Bendis is a good writer
yes Brian Michael Bendis is a great
writer the problem that is that
sometimes he does not do a very good job
worrying about continuity and that can
cause problems so let's see hems
daughter is supposed to be the MC wasp
and that would make sense you know I
mean I get the distinct pens daughter
but mm-hmm it'd be interesting um so
prob the star-lord eventually get any
superpower since he's half Spartan what
but night okay there's to break in the
music um got so many questions rolling
in here from you guys it's nuts I was
like let's let's scroll through here
unless see what's up Young Avengers TV
show I would watch that I'm watching an
Avengers TV show um nothing it'd be good
and I be it'd be interesting having
hulling as a character would be
intriguing you know but it'd be
interesting yeah check it out absorber
man got killed often agents of shield
I'll remember if he got killed off but I
remember that he he was I think he was
infected by the thing the diviner so
let's see what do you think of the new
Iron Man suit that can turn into any
previous suit and what are your top five
suits of his possible video that would
be a bad idea to do a top five video on
the suits of iron man the top five seats
I mean Hulkbuster would obviously come
in at number one a hold like a suit
designed to destroy the Hulkbuster armor
would be very very solid like I
definitely dig that what in the heck is
going on with with this whole thing do
like my flash browser just a flash just
crash like a Peter feels like it's going
haywire it's weird I blame it on the
rand paul article that i have open from
CNBC thanks CNBC thanks to obama let's
see do i think they should link the MCU
with the disney movies ah not really
sure how i feel about that um I don't
really think I'd go see a movie from the
Marvel Cinematic Universe that's tied
into the Disney movies no I don't think
I'd go see that I think that I'd I'd be
a little concerned about going to see it
would be like that what in the hell is
going on with this with
computer man with this browser freakin
let's close it all out everything for
one second guys Firefox is losing its
mind man Firefox is just crap sometimes
sometimes Firefox is really really solid
and other time as Firefox just just
shits the bed and I don't understand it
and it drives me up the wall but
whatever now firefox crap explained
Firefox sucks explained okay let's jump
back to our chat okay here we go um what
do you think of the new spider-man movie
the one coming out in July I'm looking
forward to it um it'll be weird you know
it seeing them rebooted again but it'll
be a marvel based film and I think
that's going to draw a lot of people and
because people have been wanting on
Marvel Cinematic Universe spider-man up
to this point like they've been wanting
that um it's only having creative
control I think or I gets Marvel having
creative control and Sony being involved
whatever like it's not gonna now now
it's it's going to be it's going to be
pretty awesome I get your [ __ ] together
Firefox hey Rob do you think mom will
give us a Hulk in the MCU let's see that
acts like the Hulk in the cartoon or
smutty as heroes I mean I don't think so
let me have think the hook we have the
mcd's fine right now I mean I don't see
any reason why they should change have I
read blackest night what did I think no
I haven't read that yet I have it on my
list of things to read but I haven't
read that yet let's see do you think it
was a good idea for okay that that right
there gets you banned right there user
blocked
okay derogatory terms stuff like that
will get you banned with no questions
asked guys like I'm not going i probably
i may not even tell you that it happens
i'll just banned you directly and and
that's that let's see top five fan films
based on superheroes oh um well i
haven't seen a whole lot of fan films
but i would say the dirty laundry is
number one right up there like that that
would be a solid one I just a number two
would be the spider-man 1 and then I
don't know what I do for the other three
I'm not really sure I haven't seen a
whole lot of fan films so let's see I
need to read blackest night it's really
good yeah i'll have to check it out like
i'll definitely definitely take a look
at it let's see is the is the audio
really like delayed like is it lagging
for you guys no it's not lagging this
still ok if it's lacking for you that's
your problem is it's fine i'm lyin it
really wasn't a derogatory question so
much as a comment like they were making
a derogatory statement about about a god
Peter Dinklage you know they referred to
him as a [ __ ] let me tell you
something you know if you I mean refer
to him by name you know what did you
think about Peter Dinklage playing ball
of our Trask like that was a question
that was clearly designed to be
offensive and i'll ban you without any
questions if if you choose to engage in
defense of activity on my channel so my
my banding list is growing all the time
you know there are people that put in
all kinds of rude comments and stuff
like that and it's you know I I have no
qualms about letting people know that
rear terms derogatory statements or a
problem um Rob if you could have three
powers from any hero what would they be
and what would your would be my hero
name well my hero name would obviously
be like like Rob the comic guy I hear
when I would be like how much to explain
and then my powers would be I have the
powers of sage which means that
everything that I have like my brain
works like a computer which means
everything that I see here anything that
I've ever experienced is memorized for
ever I never forget anything so I have
the perfect memory and perfect brain
function I would have the power of
clairvoyance so I'd be able to see into
the future and probably telepathy so I
could read the minds of other people
like that would be fun so hey Rob have
you seen the TV show misfits I've
watched a little bit of it but I really
couldn't get into it it was like
independent TV shows like whoa well I
will say that no offense to you guys
over there and across the pond across
the Atlantic but I've never really been
able to get into like British TV shows
like a lot of your TV shows are just
weird like really weird and then you
know that the indie shows that you guys
have are like even weirder and so I will
it wasn't able to get into and get into
the misfits but you know I've heard of
it you know I've heard of the TV show
and it looked like it was it was
interesting it just it wasn't really for
me so if all new all different uh oops
what if the all new all different Hulk
is the the baby hope from old man Logan
that'd be cool you not be interested to
see what they're going to do with that
character how that's going to grow and
how that's going to tie into everything
because I have no doubt that's going to
tie into a lot of different things so
yeah I don't know which participant and
the weekly poll podcasts would make the
best captain america Oh which member of
the weekly poll podcast so they make the
best captain america hmm they're
probably faust because because of haggis
that probably the reason why let's see
Rob what do you think of what do you
think of the idea of the MC use phase
for being the ultimate universe and
faithful phase five being battle world
it makes sense I mean I wouldn't mind
seeing the Ultimate Universe you know
some some more realistic depictions of
various characters but again let's see
that's the cool thing like with the
Marvel Cinematic Universe now this is in
a lot of ways
this is a lot of ways the Ultimate
Universe I mean the ultimate universe
was given us and I may do a video you
know what I might I might push the old
man Logan video back and do a video
about the Ultimate Universe that's a
good idea um I don't know um I don't
know maybe yeah I think I might do that
I mean I've already got the whole script
finish for old man Logan I mean I could
just crank out mine out but the ultimate
universe would be I think more
interesting yeah but the ultimate
universe is gone but people still like
the idea of the Ultimate Universe well
it's not gone completely is still doing
ultimate end so I don't know but what
was the see this is this is my
brainstorming process you know what
video should i do like Helena anyway the
Ultimate Universe what it was given to
us in the 2000s was a modern take on
superheroes you know rather than saying
ok guys this 1960s you know depiction of
spider-man is you know these
spider-man's standard and said they
adapted spider-man for the new
generation for the 2000s generation and
they gave us a you know return of those
characters I gave us you know the
Fantastic Four they gave a spider-man
they gave us the x-men you know mutants
different things like that how would
these characters look if they had
appeared for the first time and the
2000s that was the basis behind those
the entire concept of the Ultimate
Universe that's what we have in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe mean the
marvel cinematic universe is you know
what would happen if Tony Stark we came
Iron Man in like 2007 I mean in truth
the marvel cinematic universe is
actually a little bit later than the
Ultimate Universe but you know the
factor made into that's that's you know
this is pretty much the Ultimate
Universe that we're seeing right now we
just like a few members and things are
happening a little bit differently but
think if it is like an alternate version
of The Ultimate Universe you know so
that's pretty much how it happens you
know I was happening right now so um I
don't know I mean either way you know
it'll be it's it's you know I don't know
I forgot where your question was now
that i think about it what was your
question see this is the problem that i
have i get so caught up and like it like
a like answering a question i forget
what the question was no it's all good
let's see Rob your thoughts on the new
Miles Morales series or not we did I
love Miles Morales mile Miles Morales is
one of the best spirit one of the best
characters to come out of Marvel in a
long time Miles Morales and maybe I'll
do a video maybe I'll do see this is the
cool things this is what I love so you
guys are my brain storming so you guys
don't know this you guys are you guys
little do you know that when we do these
you know Marvel requests right not more
requests when we do these which that
will come back at some point when Secret
Wars is over but when we do these comics
and coffee you know the weekly Q&A like
I brainstorm like well I'm talking to
you guys like I'm thinking about videos
that I could do imagine a Miles Morales
video done like Civil War or the death
of wind Stacey like that would be mm-hmm
be very good like I definitely dig that
so we'll do a video about Miles Morales
too but I love Miles Morales as a
character he is a great a great concept
in the in the Marvel Universe I would go
as far as to say that you know him
having his own solo series isn't
anything new him he's had it you know he
also made spider-man he had that
character going on for quite some time
but you know I'd still check it out you
know the new series that he has if he's
going to be the spider-man you know i
would definitely read it you know i
would definitely you know get into it so
um let's see do we need a third company
to bring in a fresh out let aside from
Marvel in DC I don't think so I mean
maybe we'll get something like saga but
you know I don't really know I don't
think so yeah no I don't smoke weed guys
are you a fan of the new Star Wars
comics yes I love the new Star Wars
comics they are they're solid I have you
know Darth Vader number one sitting over
there and I love the new the new Star
Wars comics like they're they're pretty
solid so favorite voice actor um
probably James Earl Jones he's pretty
cool let's see who would win in a fight
without God DC or marvel that's an
interesting question that sounds like a
loaded question to be honest like who
would win DC or marvel well there's no
right answer do you see fans are going
to be if i say Marvel DC and DC fans are
gonna be like no do you see would win
and if I say DC the Marvel fans are
gonna be like no I would win so I'm
gonna say that they would tie it would
be equal so there we go um do I think
will Smith would play a good electro not
not a chance not not by a long shot Will
Smith is Will Smith is interesting he's
a quagmire Will Smith is really really
good at some roles and not very good at
other roles like Will Smith was amazing
in seven pounds will smith was amazing
in Fresh Prince that classic scene where
his dad bails out on him and he has a
statue and he's crying and uncle Phil's
crying you know and so on it's a great
great moment and you know in The Fresh
Prince of bel-air you know he has he's
had great roles over the course of his
life I personally loved his character
and i am legend he did a great job it's
just whoever wrote that movie they
screwed up the ending with the with a
script um will smith in Suicide Squad is
going to be interesting I don't know how
that's going to come out I'm not have to
check it out and I'll watch it to see
how it will be how're you it on the
intruders I don't mean I think Jamie
Foxx was a good electro but that was you
know Jamie Foxx is a great actor the
problem is that the scripts for those
movies were crap like they were absolute
garbage you know Sony doesn't know what
they're doing when they make spider-man
films and it reflects in in the movies
themselves you know spiders you know
what spider-man you know what you know
what Sony is Sony is the person that
knows nothing about about Marvel Comics
and then decides to go on a circuit
teaching people about Marvel Comics
that's sony Sony's like hey guys let's
hear here's a story about spider-man
and then when somebody says hey have you
ever read me spider-man comics you're
like well no but I mean you know
everybody knows you're spider-man is
that's that Sony let's see what Spidey
villain should be in the solo film I say
either chameleon or beetle I'm well one
it doesn't need to be anybody that we've
seen so far I would say Mysteria would
be a great choice but you know again
it's just kind of kind of up in the air
let's see uh huh where was oh hey Rob
would you be which are you more excited
for cisco becoming vibe or caitlin
McCowan killer frost definitely caitlin
becoming killer killer frost caitlin
snow beam killer frost i think is gonna
be a really cool thing it'll be
interesting to see her character from
like a villain perspective you know from
a bad guys perspective that'll be cool
um you know as she's been so like she's
iming up until this point she's been so
like by the book you know she's been so
like total line never deviate you know
always do the right thing it'll be
interesting to see what happens when
she's the other side of that when she
was just like let's just strolling all
of the wind and kill people you know
that'll be that'll be kind of fun do I
think dupe would be good and the Secret
Wars battle world tions or in his own
mini series I would read a miniseries
about dupe I loved I love the character
of dupe like he was it was so cool he
was one of the coolest introductions in
the new x-men um but that being said you
know I doubt he'd be in his own solo
series I mean a dupe solo series would
not sell let's just be honest I mean
there's like maybe five of you in this
chat who would be like I would buy a
dupe solo series but one was not going
to make a solo series if five people are
going to buy it like that's not going to
happen he'd be better off as part of
somebody else's series you know he'd be
part better off as part as like
appearing and other people's series just
kind of be like this wandering character
that roams around a different series and
appears in different books but I
couldn't see him getting his own getting
his own story and how do you feel about
Joss Whedon being Buffy being bullied
and being about him being bullied off
twitter by
angry feminists joss whedon's a grown
man you know if if the rantings and
ravings of people that he could easily
ignore were things that push them off of
twitter then there was something else
going on there I would be hard pressed
to find myself pushed off twitter by the
rants of angry people i would just start
blocking them all systematically and
then if there became so many of them
that i would just get a program that
would just automatically block them so
you know i wouldn't have to do it on my
own but but people can easily be ignored
it's that's the beauty of the internet
is is you can easily just ignore people
and push them alone I pushed him away
doop is one of the greatest characters
in the history of the x-men he is he's
someone that I just can't explain you
have to see for yourself imagine Slimer
as an x-man and that's doop he's from
like this alternate reality it's weird
or this other other dimension rather
it's it's weird but dupe is a Boop is
awesome dupas dupe have a red flash
point yes flashpoint was incredible I
loved yeah i love the flashpoint event i
loved how dark it was how gritty it was
it was it was not what i was expecting
it to be at phoenix versus the void
definitely the Fenix the Fenix would
obliterate the void no questions asked
Robert Reynolds is powerful but he's in
these no he's no Phoenix force not by a
long shot JK Simmons returning for Jay
jonah Jameson in the MCU that is fine by
me this no he's easy only he's the only
j jonah Jameson JK Simmons is the only J
jonah Jameson that we need he is he's
the Jameson we need and the one we
deserve so given the last two spider-man
films to like we definitely deserve to
have him as as jenna jameson and we've
earned that paying our money and going
to see those shitty films sitting
through there were those five hours
shitfest we deserve something good in
return hey Rob who would win apocalypse
vs doomsday um doomsday probably he
would just pummel apocalypse until he
died let's see you explain nothing now
I'm even more confused well I can't
explain dupe to you like I can't explain
him like you do is a state of mind is
what dupe is dupe is
is dupe is something that we could all
wish to aspire to you know doop is not
dupas love dupas life that's the best
way to explain it um who would win uh
you guys on your end your things like
who would win like who would who would
who would beat who like who would who
would defeat who um what happened at
franklin richards and secret wars
franklin richards is alive and well he
is at the home of dr. doom he actually
apparently just like chills with
Galactus with a giant Galactus robot or
the giant Galactus thing that's there
he's there he's just chilling around
there I mean he's still alive so um
let's see Dube is not explainable um
what do you think who do you think would
win Hulk or Hulk Hogan you guys in your
and your are we still on dupe yes we're
still undo that dupe is very important
um Rob vs. comic story and who would win
well if you guys want to see would win
between me and Benny they come out to
dallas next week and watch as we fight
to the death and then you'll find out
who would win so here's a spoiler alert
though like it's gonna be me so let's
see hey Rob would you watch a Hawkeye
standalone movie or something when I
watch a Hawkeye standalone movie or
something what's the other something I
mean is it like I mean I don't know what
if I don't know what the other something
was be I would watch a Hawkeye
standalone movie I mean it has to be
interesting that too i like his bat his
past like the whole backstory i would
check that out and then i'm sure i'm
probably one of the minority I don't
think many people would you know but I
think I'd go check it out I couldn't
they couldn't hurt
dubas love I say dupas life removal all
is not doomed in his dupe yes actually
is do you 00 p d 00 p dupe it'sit's i
know it sounds weird but it's dupe what
do you think of Booster Gold boo circles
and okay character I don't really got
into Booster Gold I mean the last time I
remember Booster Gold he was no never
mind that was Blue Beetle he was getting
a hell beat out of him by doomsday I
don't know much about Booster Gold oh no
really I'm not really that concerned
about it I mean I never really got into
him so what you see they this is a mango
strawberry cream flavored juice um how's
the gym life going now it's going fine I
mean it doesn't hurt his more or didn't
I wouldn't say hurt is not as sore as i
used to be you know when I was
consistent like when I first started
going like all the time like not nearly
a sword now it's just kinda like oh in
their workout like my muscles feel a
little weak afterwards you know but then
they you know I trying to drink a
protein shake and recover and I'm fine
so um hey Rob getting into spider-man
comics where should I start um honestly
you don't really start anywhere anytime
soon um if you want to get into
spider-man comics that would wait unless
you want to read old stories if you want
to be current I say read Miles Morales
ultimate spider-man that's really all
you need I mean let's see hey Rob any
thoughts on Shane from the walking dead
as the punisher yeah we actually talked
about that earlier he's a great actor i
think is a great call I think it's a
great decision to to have him there I'm
pretty psyched about it so you said it
was a guava you like yeah like it's
called it's called gamma by cloud signs
come on let's see what it is cloud
science gamma at giant waves yes by T
Leo's mango payers Oh mango guava and
then peaches and cream so yeah mango
guava peach and cream yeah it's a it's
an 8020 blend yeah it's pretty damn good
too like I really like it my I'm using
three milligrams I tried to use six and
I thought I was going to die like it was
it was nuts how bad it was burning my
throat Donald Doug versus Howard the
Duck Howard the Duck any day of the week
Batman versus black panther that would
be a great battle i would say black
panther but you know again they're very
evenly matched in terms of intelligence
and physical prowess like they're very
very evenly matched Rob what's your PC
settings like I have a I 7 59 60 X
running at 4 gigahertz overclocked 32
gigabytes of 2133 megahertz ram
megahertz whatever it is 2133 ram i've
got i actually just recently got the the
intel 750 series SSD the 450 or 400
gigabyte one so it's got like you know
two thousand gigabytes read and write or
two ticket bites read and write I've got
the gtx titan x graphics card this
thing's a beast this thing's this
thing's a hoss they can do I could like
it launched rockets into space using
this computer like this thing is pretty
solid um Rob what speedster should be in
flash season 2 Wally West I really want
to see Wally West and flash season 2 I
want to see him mentioned or something I
want to see him in existence like that
would be super cool let's see Runaways
number one thought it sucked how about
you not a big fan of The Runaways now
don't say that around Foust like Faust
will flip his [ __ ] if you say like
Runaways suck he'll get all bad a shape
and angry like it's funny hey Rob what
do you see as possibilities
so many questions and I got us go back
down again what do you see as well now I
lost the question Damon so many
questions that come in it's so difficult
to keep track of them all um 1.21
jigowatts let's see why don't you tubers
reply to comments that's actually very
interesting question the question I'm
not going to answer but there is a
reason why let's see do you prefer new
x-men or astonishing x-men mm-hmm god I
don't man these headphones don't hurt my
ears I need to get some new headphones i
think i'm gonna go to best buy today and
get some new headphones well no crap
they closed they closed already like I
need to get some new headphones these
headphones are those headphones aren't
cutting it very nice but there they
cause like this like the soreness right
here like there's a sore right on my ear
right up there and it [ __ ] hurts um
let's see Tony start a tony dize on
civil war instead of cap I'm an illegal
happen let's see have you ever been
recognized when you walk around in your
local area yes I've been I've been
recognized before it's funny it's really
humbling like it's weird you know like
I'm just kind of like well I mean things
I think I like I went to my my local
comic store and somebody was like hey
you're Robb and I was like that what's
going on and and it's cool cuz I mean we
just talked like we just geeked out just
like nerd it out about comics so it's
just like I was like yeah man I'm like I
love this story I love that story they
were like what do you think about this
and that's all they really did it they
just kept asking me questions about
comics and I was like let's talk about
something besides comics like anything
besides comics like don't just ask me
questions about comics like it's weird
so um get headphones that cover the ears
but over it yeah i might get like some
boasts some bose like noise cancellation
headphones or something like that like
those are really really so
so there we go do I prefer new x-men or
astonishing x-men astonishing x-men was
really good new x1 was okay i didn't
really dig it too much let's do that
then i think was a grant morrison x-men
I don't really dig him too much grant
morrison was weird when it came to the
x-men like let's just wipe out Genosha
like it was weird um you know i'd like
to sauna she acts when my joss whedon's
run of astonishing x-men um let's see do
you think we will see the defenders and
Captain America 3 I don't think so the
Captain America 3 comes out next year
and the defenders won't form for another
two years I think so we're not going to
see the defenders in Captain America 3
we may see them in infinity war but we
won't see him in Captain America 3 now
we might get some mentioning of
daredevil who may even you may even have
a cameo but but I think that's it let's
see Rob didn't you want to see cap died
in the Civil War movie how did I want to
see cap dinosaur movie yes I want to see
like the death of Captain America event
doesn't have to be in a civil war movie
but I do want to see the death of
Captain America event because that was a
big deal which will also do a video
about the death of Captain America so
may I suggest the astro a40 s yeah but I
don't want to buy gaming headphones i
want to buy like good quality sound
headphones so Rob what's the biggest
difference between Peter Parker and
Miles Morales well actually you know I'm
going to save that answer will discuss
that in in my video about Miles Morales
because that is a really good that's a
really good question to answer in that
video Rob what's your favorite fruit
oranges I love oranges let's see Bradley
bowel man Bradley Powell everybody in
the chat everyone everyone in the chat
like what I want you guys to do is I
want you guys to say
and Bradley Powell great question just
try to say Bradley Powell great question
Bradley Powell has been asking
relentlessly Pym particles made from
vibranium a thought I guess he wants my
thoughts on Pym particles being made
from vibranium what my thought is on
that Bradley pal the answer to your
question is I have no idea if that's the
case or not but if they are it would be
kind of cool I mean it'd be it'd be
interesting um I wouldn't really have a
problem with it I think it would be
nothing to be intriguing I mean you know
I don't know how it would all how it
would all come together I don't know how
it would all work I think that
everybody's in their final eval great
question great question it's funny
watching you guys do this Bradley Powell
are you happy now your question has been
acknowledged by both the chat and myself
everyone sees the value of your question
no I think that the Pym particles be
made out of vibranium I don't think
that'll happen I mean here's the thing
guys the only reason why we're seeing so
much mention of vibranium is because by
vibrating is being established as the
stand and for adamantium and the Marvel
Universe you know that our Marvel
Cinematic Universe that's all that is
you know all they're doing is they're
saying like you know that this is the
establishment this is how this works now
you know this is this is how it all
comes together that's my name don't wear
it out that's this this all vibranium is
vibranium isn't really like the key
element and everything it's just Marvel
saying hey guys and the Marvel Cinematic
Universe this is the strongest element
there is uh no I don't really think
we're going to see Pym particles be made
out of vibranium they may be they may
not be but the power of Pym particles
doesn't come from the fact that they're
made of vibranium it comes to the fact
that they can decrease or increase the
size of anything so you know that's the
power of Pym particles a few more
questions guys and I'm going to bounce
off here there's going to be a shorter
one I line to get to work on
to write the script for the Miles
Morales video I need to write the script
for the age of Hot Lips videos I need to
work on Rob explain video I gotta get a
whole bunch stuff to do today nor so um
how did Civil War start filming oops
let's see the okay I don't know what
happened to that question all right uh
Rob which one of the upcoming pardon
pardon me which one of the upcoming
Marvel movies and I'm most excited for i
would say probably Captain America 3
that's when i'm looking forward to the
most after Captain America 3 definitely
the Inhumans and black panther so those
those movies are a long way out so I'll
go and see all the other ones but I'm
pretty psyched to see the new the new
inhumans movie and and the Black Panther
movie um let's see do I think moon I
should get a TV series or a movie
definitely a series again I think it's a
much cheaper alternative to create a
series scary to create a netflix series
based on characters they're not sure
about or to feature them in the Netflix
series of characters if they're not sure
about making their characters mark
knight or I guess that Marc Spector moon
night would be a great character to have
in like you know daredevil or am The
Punisher series or something like that
is a way to introduce them in and to
effectively kind of test the waters to
see how people would feel about their
characters aside from that though you
know it'd be far more expensive to take
a little huge gamble by making them
making a movie about me you know moon
night when people are just kind of like
who the hell's moon night like we have
you know hardcore comic fans are going
to know who moon night is but casual
moviegoers aren't and so it's going to
be difficult for them to for them to
know you know who those individuals are
and to really make a good decision on
whether not they want to go see the
movie or not so let's see what are your
thoughts on Batman as the its blade
still still relevant no blades not
relevant anymore blade I think had a
role and like original sin blades not
relevant anymore like it's nobody cares
about late I good I haven't read a story
about blatant decades so let's see
thoughts on sinister six in the MCU not
really caring don't really care about
the Sinister Six that much I think it
was it's if Marvel makes the Sinister
Six into a group
and the Marvel Cinematic Universe I
think it'll be a terrible idea I don't
really care about the Sinister Six that
much um let's see have you bought
anything during the steam summer sale
know I've been looking but I haven't
really seen any games that jumped out at
me like I played fallout 3 i've played
you know chivalry I've played the all
the Assassin's Creed games i mean i'm
not i'm kind of on the fence there
really is anything that jumps out to me
so um let's see Rob who wins Goku or
Superman and why is it Goku it's not
it's Superman so Superman would win that
battle have the X titles improved since
secret wars or will they well I think
about it this way guys secret worse is
wrapping up a lot of those titles so you
know the all-new x-men is going to be
going away you know around guess maybe
continuing on its own thing not really
sure but nonetheless the ex titles are
decent there now they're nothing to run
home without you know but they're
interesting to me they you know I was an
x-men fan for years and years and years
and years and then they just kind of got
dumb and so I just stopped watching them
or stop reading them and really didn't
get into it that much anymore so anyway
guys we're going to go ahead and in this
one again and I've got a whole bunch of
scripts to write a whole bunch of videos
to work on so I wouldn't love to keep
this going I'd love for this to be a
little bit longer but you know again
this is gonna be a shorter ones only
going to be about an hour so and ND ass
so so ya peeps mob peeps um again for
the little guys were going to be in
dallas an AHA or Dallas Arlington me and
Vinny and Drake will be there next week
probably on the 23rd or 24th for those
of you guys who are who are going to be
in New York myself binny South faust
been Ethan Tiffany Danielle you know
we're all going to be there for New York
Comic Con this year um and yeah um yeah
maybe I'll make sure you guys check out
Rob explains so if you guys haven't
already make sure you guys take a look
at Rob explains in the new channel where
I explain stuff outside of comic books
so so yeah anyway I'm going to go ahead
mouse off here and I will catch you guys
later peace